I'm gonna share the new link
just wait we're live tell us you can
hear us before we do anything else on
this stream citizens of the reject
nation and then we'll kick this off
properly just tell us that you can hear
us is there snare in our headphones
is their snare is there snaring the
headphones people yes so we got
ourselves some sound okay all right I'm
excited I'm excited to do this all right
thank you guys for bearing with us I'm
going to delete uh the previous stream
so there's no confusion because
sometimes that stuff happens
um but ladies and gentlemen we got
here's the story of what happened this
morning
um I was going I was on my way to the
gym and then uh I like to meditate in
the sauna beforehand and then I
meditated and then I have to do my
podcast with Paul heavy spoilers and
he's like oh we got this Wolverine news
I'm like Wolverine news and he said it's
like right before I started working out
and I was like what and then I call it
can you get here right now I was
changing to go to the gym but this is
priority I was like this and so and I
was like let's just go live because this
is exactly what Corey and I and a lot of
us have been wanting for so long I feel
like a lot you guys have been wanting
this as well before we dive into any of
that I want to thank all of you guys for
being here we can't be live for that
long today normally do just like two to
three hours we only got maybe at most
like 45 minutes to an hour of course
stream live super chats are are
absolutely welcome
um we got so many last time but we don't
end the stream without you know going
through all of them also this Saturday
this upcoming Saturday night not the in
the 11 days Comic-Con we're gonna be
there and we've got a panel at 1pm 1pm
Comic-Con in the library which is a big
old room so let's fill it with rejects
it is an honor to be at San Diego
Comic-Con much less a Saturday panel
much less a big old room so let's fill
it with reject Nation Saturday 1pm
Comic-Con be there alrighty guys yes
we're looking for a common compound now
let's hop into it
um I'm gonna just say this right away
I'm surprised by the sleeves I don't
think they last this you don't you think
he'll eventually rip off the sleeves I
think the sleeves go I'm just happy that
it looks like the animated costumes and
all of its beautiful Glory I mean look
at it guys it's absolutely gorgeous in
in all the ways that we want it to be
because this both Deadpool and Wolverine
feel more like Deadpool might not look
drastically different but it looks a
little brighter and it's got a little
like accoutrement like look at the chest
piece the chest is a little bit more
accented also the Deadpool belt if you
look at the belt he's actually got his
own face on his crotch which I respect
uh there's a little bit of gold in the
sleeves and in the gloves uh his
knuckles have a little bit of gold on
the accessories and the overall red is
brighter and a lot of people were
complaining it was too bright today
you're wrong one two if it wasn't
brighter it wouldn't work with Wolverine
because if he was the darker red leather
and Wolverine was that vibrant that
wouldn't be ketchup and mustard that'd
be like some toast and mustard so this I
think is the move I also think it allows
for the ketchup mustard vibrancy that is
the MC you take these guys are gonna be
Multiverse hopping a brightness works
for this yeah it really really does oh
my God and uh look she's I love all the
details here let me see if I can
accentuate it here on the live stream
for everyone here all right here we go
so
right there just the cloth
right when I was a little kid that was
one of the things that always stood out
to me was that he had a section and if
you look at it it's not in in the movies
they would come from remember in here in
between the knuckles no they're giving
them coming out from above here more
comic accuracy and that is something I
don't think a lot of people are really
paying attention to yeah because that is
more comics accurate to be coming from
up there because if this is my first
time really exactly by the way I saw a
brief image on my phone I was like come
over here this is the first time we've
done it live for news because this is
the most exciting thing uh so if you
look also at the sides uh so like where
his obliques are show me the obliques
the obliques where they cut in right
here so that is mirroring uh the actual
comic book uh iteration that is from the
astonishing X-Men run which has been
talked about a lot it's it's what Joss
Whedon did for you know the character
and that is one of the more modern takes
on the suit but this ties into the
original suit which is the one with the
whiskers when his first appearance yeah
I sent you that image uh so this is
going to be a nice blend of all the
different costumes but still hit the
iconic color palette because it's
actually blue not black yeah a lot of
people were looking at this and seeing
but if you look at the shoulder pads in
this like beautiful color this is a blue
and yellow suit this is like this is
right I know
the guys they actually did it can we
just celebrate this for a second like if
this was the one I said this in the last
live stream that one of the things that
I felt like had to be fulfilled that if
you were going to bring Wolverine back
it's give him the yellow costume at the
end of the Wolverine there was a deleted
scene where he they tease it he would
get the yellow costume he did not get
the yellow suit never did and then if
you're gonna bring him over to the MCU
for any appearance I'm like this this
gets you where are they by the way I
thought about that they're in the valley
I think this is like a candid shot of
Hugh and Ryan like not even a still from
the movie uh so the hair feels a lot
more trimmed yeah it looks like the
Wolverine hair however what I'm noticing
is there's no mask there is no mask yet
do you think there will eventually be a
bad mask I think we get a mask I think I
also think and this is maybe a hot take
I think we're gonna get many Deadpool
suits and many Wolverine suits because I
think Wolverine is going to be uh sought
after I think that we we I said this on
our live stream I think that we see the
Logan that died and then I think Hugh
Jackman is going to play multiple
Wolverines I think we might get patch I
think we might get the brown and yellow
suit that got teased in that deleted
scene that never got released I think we
get this I think we get sleeveless I
think we get masked uh I think we have a
lot I think we get a lot uh someone
mentioned the belts I also love the
belts uh the actual X-Men belt the
actual that whole belt are our
highlights for me look at these
beautiful let's enhance everyone once
enhance Chrome shot there it is look at
that beautiful crotch so much Canadian
and Australian love in this image uh I
mean these are perfect belts uh not only
do you have the pouches for for Deadpool
the the Rob life feltastic uh but you
are also bringing in the more
um streamline modernized like Danger
Room X-Men suits here with with
Wolverines I'm glad it's not too ornate
I know a lot of people get mad at Marvel
over costuming but this is exactly what
I'd expect from a screen anchor
Wolverine suit oh yeah
you know we're just gonna get so many
cool cam I feel like this movie's gonna
be the one that truly does this is gonna
do the one that everyone wanted for
Multiverse and Madness I just can't
believe it's blue I can't believe it's
blue and yellow like I'm looking at it
I've seen it all morning I've stared at
it it might be my phone back grab a
little bit of a comparison
um oh let me just adjust this really
quick let's just get a bit of a
comparison thing here because you sent
some comparison photos I did I want
everyone to be able to see that and
obviously we're against the super chats
yeah we will definitely be getting to
those reading the enhance all right so
which photo was it koi that you wanted
to show off okay so uh this one uh yes
so this is I said at the top the
astonishing X-Men uh this is the suit
that I think it mirrors most
um you'll see here that it's got the
cuts and the obliques that I was talking
about it also has the paneling down the
side of the legs it's got the blue and
yellow instead of doing like the piratey
arch on the boot it does a double layer
boot which I think is clever one of the
big issues with superhero costumes is
there's always this inclination to do
like like this pirate boot uh and it
kind of looks
so instead of the pirate boot they did
like a double layer uh can you just
scroll down to the the lower thigh yeah
yeah I got you man I got you thank you I
think I think this is a really clever
decision do you see how uh like a pirate
boot kind of pulls up uh instead of
doing like a pull-up like that and they
did like a double layer so he's got a
standard Boot and then a stripe of blue
color on the more uh you know regular
costume and that gives you the sense of
the shape of a pirate booty without it
actually looking silly so if you go just
below the knee uh see how there's like
that double layer I think that's a
really clever way to nod because then it
gives the idea of the shape yeah so you
see how like he's got a blue line and
then uh then yeah and then on his suit
on Hughes do you see how they do that
blue stripes and that gives it the
appearance of even more of a pirate
booty and I think that's really clever
right so instead of this shape which
would look silly they do like the the
the mind fills it in because that looks
like a it works
it's beautiful I think it's beautiful
I'm just sure look how pretty it is it's
so pretty it's so pretty and then if you
uh roll up
and now you've got
you've got eggs which gives you that
streamlined look uh we already talked
about the claws wait slow down Cory
which part okay his legs his hips I love
that the blue paneling goes under the
belt like it does in the comic so both
Hue and comic I'll say comic and Hue
they both have that blue paneling all
the way down to the side to mid thigh do
I need to go to a different part that's
perfect
this is my job to make sure I got photos
on screen photos all right so I love
that it goes under the belt and it gives
them that full side body look and then
you got the oblique inlay yellows yes
but it's all like suddenly done it's not
a lot of changes but it looks more
regular like this the Hue suit looks
like it could exist like that could just
walk around yeah and then uh I do think
the sleeves at some point are gonna go
I'm kind of glad it's got like uh the
option of the big big gloves and then
the shoulder pads and scroll up just a
little bit more to the shoulder area you
got it there it is and then okay so one
of the things that's been with every
suit uh I'd say 98 of Wolverine suits
have that slight shoulder extension over
the edge I don't think we've seen seen
that done in a comic book movie well uh
it either looks like they've got like
big 80s shoulders or it looks like a a
football player outfit this is what a
comic I always thought would look like
like it's it's obviously over the
shoulder it extends but it looks like
something that's almost practical so it
just slightly goes over but if you pull
up any Wolverine costume nobody talks
about it he's got kind of like some
shoulder Patty area and this and that's
the thing I never thought we'd see
that's beautiful so excited mask is
coming it's perfect
yes I'm just so so happening okay
all right what's going on in this chat
right now so good let me pull back up
the uh the other photo here
um
yeah I'm at a loss for words so all I
have is Zach Tyler he's got an x on his
belt that's X-Men branding that's about
his X-Men is again did you eat today koi
uh no I'm not eating I'm not I'm very
hungry enough to seven in the morning I
had a athletic greens nice ag-1 yeah ag1
and then uh you normally my day goes I I
work out and I get my brain a little
sharp nice and I missed that part but
I'm here just to just to moderate the
screen
we're teaming up on this yeah no I'm
starving uh but uh actually let's let's
quickly go over to let's go do you think
they gave him sleeves so that way he had
time to bulk up a little bit throughout
the course of this movie since I shot it
pretty fast it seems I think that
Wolverine is not usually because it
doesn't look as tight fitting yeah no
like if you look at the pants area not
to criticize the beautiful Hugh
Jackman's physique but specifically in
the crotchal region I mean right if you
look at Ryan Reynolds comparatively
let's zoom out across this looks Tighter
and this looks a tad looser you know
know what I mean well I think it's not
as tight fitting like Eddie Ramirez is
saying in the chat where's the collagen
right now
although his thighs look a little large
they're pretty they're pretty like he's
doing leg next
I would say they gave him sleeves one to
give him time like you're saying but two
like Hugh Jackman is uh tall and
Wolverine is short so I think allowing
um a little bit more play in the costume
will help him not look quite as like
lengthy like whether he's jacked or not
that is a tall man so you want a stocky
Wolverine and he only had so much time
so I I think it's a combination of
things I mean regardless I think right
now what you look as a physical
appearance and here's the other thing
too I mean this looks like an official
release photo because Hugh Jackman
posted this himself a lot of times you
get these like set leaks we would not
post or do a video about a Paparazzi
photo let the record show maybe uh I
would not but but at the same time uh
this is an official photo so it's like
you're not even seeing it in an actual
motion right now um and the the cool
thing about that is really just being a
step vote it still looks great it looks
a lot of times these stat photos don't
look that great granted it's more of an
official release right it's not like an
Entertainment Weekly release but like an
Empire they release an 8K the Deadpool
Twitter was like here's more here's more
and they just kept enhancing it which
made me happy I've been saying for the
longest time uh people have constantly
been asking for a long time like what's
your most exciting MCU movie coming up
and I feel like a lot of people don't
list this one this one listen I'm like
this is the reason this is the most
exciting reason this and Beyond the
spider verse are my two most anticipated
pieces of Cinema all right uh can we
zoom in on Deadpool briefly it won't be
as long it won't be as long of a
breakdown yeah real quick dude quiet
please okay because I got I got some
thoughts okay so we're gonna get to all
the comments and stuff properly we're
just making we're still reading them
simultaneously yeah we're catching them
as we go so Deadpool uh you'll notice
that this is actually Ryan Reynolds by
the shape of his head uh his stunt
doubles uh their heads are slightly
different because they've got to make
room for the eyeballs and stuff so this
is actually Ryan in there which is I'm
sure you don't release an image of these
two without it actually being Ryan but
uh if you look at the actual uh
Fasteners they've added gold to uh the
actual artwork yeah that the gold let's
enhanced coins
so he's actually got gold along with the
brown which is not in the original uh
Deadpool one and two suit so he's got a
little bit more layering and adds a
little bit more texture
um the line work in his chest is
different so where it comes down from
the neck piece down to the chest that's
new this this was just a solid red and
that I think allows for a little bit
more of look of ABS it allows for a
little bit more not just being one red
big red condom as he calls it and then
if you get down to the Belt uh that's
gonna be way more gold in detail I got
one job to do okay and hand soon enhance
uh so now we've got the actual belt
which is a much more lie felty with all
the gold and the the accents here but
this I think allows for those little
texture flashes of color that add just a
little bit more comic versus real world
and I think if you look at the tone of
the movie this is going to be more
comic-y Deadpool 2 was especially like
greedy with cable and like you know the
the marina background character biting
it I think we're gonna play more I think
this is gonna be a lot more playful and
the suit reflects that if you go down to
uh a little bit more to his knee you'll
notice
scratches I think it's after a fight oh
good catch look at that oh solid catch
there koi three claw marks I'm just
saying
good satch hold on hold on guys my
enhance abilities are a little off right
now okay there we go
oh good pool I'm pretty pretty happy to
think about how they might have a fight
scene oh they have to they must guys all
I'm saying is we're currently looking at
an image of claw marks on Deadpool's
thigh standing next to a comicat here at
Wolverine suit oh and look at this I
just want to say that happened
seven marks ah the seven that's after
their fight yeah after they make up and
they it's kind of like that black bear
with Anthony Mackie sometimes sometimes
you gotta fight first they're they're
fighting and then they're effing you
know what I mean yeah uh I'm so happy
I'm so happy I'm so happy like look at
this look at your screen right now just
take a moment for you that's on screen I
know hold on what no no no no no no coin
what what's on screen right now is my
enhance abilities
ever since Greg discovered some OBS
ideas
game right now
the thigh claw it made me so happy when
I first saw it oh Galaxy you say I
wonder if they're from scratch from a
different version of Wolverine I would
assume I think that uh actually you know
what he might fight comic you know I
wanted to say great job oh I'm breaking
down those these pics
that was really impressive
I was like driving you're like extremely
impressive when he just I know a lot of
people are like yeah koi talks that's
yeah striking vipers is the reference I
had uh yeah dude that was really
so I could be like guys I read nothing I
just came in and I was here to just move
stuff around on the screen I'm still
having I was happy to be here for that
to be right here for you this is like
the wall screen of the wallpaper I
always wanted my desktop to be able to
have it's a great wallpaper coin
stunning great wallpaper all right do
you want to get some uh yeah let's get
let's get some chats in here really
quick who's the latest comment right now
let's just read the the latest comment
ketchup and mustard you win it's true
that is what it is let me just adjust
this that's why he had to be a little
brighter it tonally works better how far
behind are we on this on the chat you
know
okay let's see here where are we at
um
enough said New York you know we are
gonna get a bub in this guaranteed I
also think this might be the first time
we get Wolverine a cigar because it's
gonna be rated R people aren't talking
about that aspect we get a cigar
chomping logo we got a cigar and yeah
and like one of the old X-Men but it was
before they changed I remember an X-Men
the Last Stand yeah yeah no he's had
something like all of them right well
they eventually stop but because they
legally my image always goes back to
whatever my mind always goes back to
X-Men the Last Stand when they're
fighting the Sentinels at the beginning
that's part of that whole movie yeah uh
but I think I think I've been on a cigar
I think that's the last time he was able
to have it because they changed the law
the MPAA is if you smoke it's all rated
now so this is what yep there's if
there's smoking it's it's already
that can't be true yeah I think
cigars and like our rating I'm gonna
google it
what I blame Kathleen Kennedy she did
this she changed things what a what a
terrible what that is that's ridiculous
there's no way what do you mean we're in
a Star Wars video what Star Wars video
are you talking about any film that
shows or implies tobacco is rated R as
of uh was he in the uh did he smoke in
and and Logan at all
um he smoked a cigar next to Days of
Future passing Logan too and yes Don
Stewart saying in the chat too he had
one in in in The Last Stand so uh
already films he's been smoking for a
long time guys I'm just saying that's
the law MPAA 20 and I'm saying 2018.
what you're talking 2018 the law so
again now he can smoke again because
it's all rated I love how there's okay
gutter punk you got gutter punk in the
chat who's like upset about a couple of
things like no cowboy boots no
fingerless goes okay look it's more
accurate than we've ever had before and
I think that warrants enough
why why so particular yeah and it sets a
civilian outfit like what do you mean
I'm confused by the statement also what
I don't know all right as long as we're
all confused I don't want to attack
people who are in our stream sometimes I
know koi will yes I'm here for you I'm
here for you guys uh let's see let's see
I vaguely remember hearing about that
tobacco loss yeah a lot more came in
than I would expected we're like we're
gonna be live for a little bit thank you
guys
all right we're gonna we're gonna hyper
Focus here we got this we got this all
right okay I forgot the last stream was
about Deadpool as well so I I was I was
a little oh okay I was like well that's
not that's a lot today okay here we go
there's the also someone pointed out
that I'm dressed like Deadpool and
you're dressed like Wolverine and that's
great yeah like perfect he's got the
Dead He's Got The Wolverine muscles yeah
I got
I I got half the muscles so Jack in the
last three months I appreciate look at
all the comments on the in the written
and the live chat the people notice that
people notice all right hold on let me
just adjust this a little bit oh the the
Ahsoka trailer there's an Ahsoka trailer
this is more important yeah I'm sorry
wait wait we're in an Ahsoka trailer
like it's credited what are you talking
about let's explain yourself what you
talking about what we're talking about
here man oh I'm so excited okay all
right okay your super chat we'll get red
because we're ready Bucky Barnes Atlanta
here we go guys um if Wolverine has that
yellow stinky Bucky Barnes he is also
the moderator if you guys are here
please uh leave a like on this video If
Wolverine has the yellow suit for real
my prior 11 year old self May Cry I was
just playing the X-Men arcade game in my
game room much love gents you know what
I really want them to do for for this
because whenever I think of animated
Wolverine I think about the first
episode of X-Men this animated series
remember the character morph yeah oh
what if they put Sentinels in this movie
I think we're actual Center actual
sentence not weird nanotech you
know whatever whatever that was dude I
think we're gonna talk in real set like
this
mutants star like just cheesy like this
everything about this seems like it's
going for the animated appeal it's more
animated comics accurate than than the
other two Deadpool movies and that's
what I mean like by them adding the
colors and the details and all those
like it's crazy okay so I do think uh
we're gonna get those moments that we've
never gotten I think that Deadpool is
going to be the fan service of X-Men
I've said it a hundred thousand times
Brian Singer made it great Brian Singer
mutant movies but to my money we've
never gotten an X-Men movie I like those
movies they are the gateway to how we
got here blade Spider-Man X-Men or how
we got here but now it's time for X-Men
Seattle coat KO remembers it this one's
for you morph and then he starts
slashing the back yeah we might actually
get a Berserker rage here too like yeah
we're gonna get all sorts of greatness
easily most anticipated all right uh
Collide missed y'all oh he's got a twin
wait do I still have these inputted oh
koi are they still in there
if people give 20s
yes
anyway thank you for this contribution
here uh Leia Ariana Bonnie uh thank you
for the Super Chat do you think this
will be the best Deadpool movie
that there has been some cause for
concern for okay here's the thing I've
noticed this with Disney kind of
happened within it kind of it definitely
happened with Indiana Jones at the dial
of Destiny there's two forms of leaks
that that generally tend to happen is
that one is it's so overblown that it
creates so much hype and then people are
disappointed the other form of leaks
it's weirdly Spider-Man no way home was
the only one that seemed to be
impervious to this that was like
bulletproof to this but the other form
of leaks is they go so overblown in such
a negative way like what happened with
dial with Destiny that people are then
like already mad at the movie before and
I've noticed there's two camps of that
happening with uh Deadpool three my only
concern with Deadpool 3 of why it might
not be the best one is due to the fact
that there's a writer strike happening
and they had to shoot it in the middle
of a writer strike when it comes to
making great films they often have to be
Rewritten as you're doing it this movie
needs the improv I know we have the
thing we're like they're wearing masks I
could do ADR but if Logan doesn't have a
mass he can't do ADR and his mask all
his ADR is like over the shoulder
stresser like well deep faking stuff you
know what I mean uh so that's my only
concern of why I I'm not 100 confidently
the best Deadpool movie I think this
could be one of the most exciting MCU
movies though because I think we will be
going to all the fox Universe movies you
know yeah I think we're gonna get cameos
that are fan service and also ending of
continuities and careers I think this is
It's kind of our dream so I honestly
think this could be the best Deadpool
movie and best X-Men movie if it
delivers well but I think that first
Deadpool movie is something really
special yeah I know it's been a couple
years so people don't talk about it
because we only have attention spans of
gnats but that first movie really
changed comic book movies and the reason
it made almost a billion dollars is what
it became so I I it's got a lot of
potential but it's gonna be hard to top
that first one yeah man I mean
um I I will watch the uh Ahsoka trailer
uh yeah I'm very confused about that
also the only thing Andrew Tate's gonna
be in is prison uh he's not gonna be hey
Koi Koi that's half of our audience well
they can leave no oh I mean we might be
in the Super Shoes
all right what do we got now we're
anti-tage until like oh you're
contributed to the super all right cool
until his money yeah Sean Payton with a
20. oh
oh
Sean Payton I do think this will break 1
billion by the way cue you uh it says in
the chat uh hey Greg and John you're the
new John apparently no there's no new
John there's a genre it's not here uh
yeah John probably didn't even know
about this honestly
um glad to catch this live I am really
liking the new look of Wolverine and
Deadpool my most anticipated of the
movie of the next year Koya Made Me Love
Comics he didn't love Comics before you
what do you know keep up the great work
guys hashtag sleeve's gone that better
be part of their reshoots because I
think that's going to be a thing a lot
of people are asking for is that if it's
not in the movie I feel like they're
gonna be like we gotta go back and shoot
yeah you got to take the sleeves off you
just gotta do it you know what I mean I
think it's almost guaranteed that
there's no way these two guys don't know
as much of our passion as we know of
these characters if you watch that first
Deadpool it is literally Ryan Reynolds
going hey you guys have wanted this for
25 years let's do it and I feel like
Hugh Jackman wouldn't come back unless
it was him doing all the things he
always wanted to do as the character
unless it was filling in the fan service
moments and his moments of of like
Wolverine so I think sleeves are coming
off hmm you know I oh yeah angel that I
have seen X-Men evolution when I was
young when it was first airing I watch
it every Saturday morning at like 9 00
a.m I think it was like a channel 11
here in in California Fox is what it was
um so yeah I did watch X-Men evolution
that was a good show it came out around
the time of the X-Men movies yeah if
they made some interesting character
choices but overall was good uh we don't
remind me a lot of people in the chat
have been bringing up I'm multitasking
okay a lot of people in the chat have
been bringing up saber tooth so let's
not forget to talk about the possibility
of sabertooth okay okay please don't
forget I see the captaining the guy in
the chat a lot right now
um Jordan Garza this is so much more fun
than uh you know because normally how it
goes is like when there's a breaking
news on breakers like shoot it time for
10 or 15 minutes oh we got a hit I gotta
make a thought oh God it'll be on the
next six hours oh my God yeah I like
that I like ag1 I take it every morning
uh Jordan Garza thank you so much for
the Super Chat my friend I just wanted
to say hola first off uh love you boys
love these lives of the reject Nation
it's a good day to be a nerd uh wearing
my Wolverine shirt you know I lost my
Wolverine I don't know what happened to
it it was the perfect one from Target
which had the yellow concept yeah and
the fabric was nice again I saw a hairy
body yeah that's another thing I love
about Hugh Jackman's Harry him and Henry
Cavill in a day and age when everyone's
shaving their goddamn bodies to show off
their like chests and abs and stuff
Henry Cavill and Hugh Jackman have been
willing to keep it full on Harry and
still let them muscles pop although he
did shave actually on a couple of them
didn't he did he did yeah I don't know
sometimes yeah
I can't remember if it was like trimmed
or if it was completely hairless I feel
like it was hairy but he's so shredded
do you guys know in the chat can you let
us know let us know let us let us know
in the chat
please let us know love the hairy chest
that's right okay thank you so much uh
let's see here
he was old I might not be able to think
this no no no he will hey if if freaking
uh uh Josh Brolin was able to buff up
yeah he's Hugh Jackman Hugh Jackman his
name is huge jacked man there's no
version of him that isn't a huge jacked
man kutsuti venue thank you for the
Super Chat love you guys hella excited
for Deadpool 3 as are we
he was not Harry in Days of Future Past
so that was the one that was the one he
was in here okay because he was in the
70s which isn't a very time
it's the hairiest at times
the future contrarian
Harry in the Wolverine it did get to a
point where he wasn't that hairy in the
Wolverine I don't think he was Harry I
think that was the trimmed one yeah
because he was Harry and Logan because
he was just he was like obnoxiously buff
in the world that was the buffest that
was the craziest his vascularity was
nuts so you can see his pulse in his
like sleeves yeah yeah really enjoy I
hope he remains hairy here he was Harry
in hashtag Harry yes uh was it was X-Men
one in 2001 where he was just like I
just got cast I'm a guy I'm pretty sure
listen he's like hey I'm hairy but I'm
also just a guy uh I think Deadpool 3
will be called Deadpool versus
um
yeah cause yeah the joke was Wolverine
and Deadpool so I think it's gonna be
Deadpool movie okay okay another one
okay so the a couple things have been
brought up in the chat we gotta we gotta
think about this who who are they gonna
be this don't let me forget who are
going to be the saber tooth Sabertooth
who's gonna villain yeah
uh Lucina pistol Fanta thank you so much
for the 10. oh oh we got a 10.
nope no don't can't do it for this
stream because that's a that's something
that's a Superman I was trying to do a
variety there this is we'll just do this
one
maybe Spider-Man shows up all right so
the costume costume great like I said in
the last one I hope Toby Maguire shows
up to fight uh for a little bit just to
have an internet
pull that pay that off 2001 Kevin feige
reference the costumes look great but
can talk about koi's cool Tyler Durden
haircut yeah it's not in the thumbnail
because
um yeah we were in a rush I was looking
through my phone went do I have any old
photos of koi
as she was coming I was looking at a
thumbnail and then he said yeah I feel
so we got her before you leave I gotta
take a photo you update that thumbnail
but yeah I loved I was saying this in
the last stream uh this is the koi I
would watch uh for years on YouTube
before I ever met him this look where I
was like this isn't uh Casey from
Nerdist
Multiverse of Madness it's OG koi
internet with new school real rejects
yeah which I dig I appreciate you
you guys show me some arm workouts koi
because I've noticed like my arms only
look good when I'm flexing see I've been
working on this one I mean like your arm
actually just looks naturally big and I
need to get to that it's the it's the
under that I'm trying to build up like
oh so just like resting but yeah like
you got like big resting arm I got like
I only look all right when I'm flank you
know what I mean so it's it's about the
peak and it's also the length uh do you
know uh because that extends the length
of your bicep and that'll give you a bit
of rest I just don't take enough protein
too but I'm only taking like 100 grams
so I I would recommend like a good
Hammer but full extension and then also
hyper extend curl so you notice like
when you uh audience when you extend
your arm in the hand this is a part of
Hugh Jackman's workout routine so a
hammer form is going to give you the
longer head of the muscle versus the
contracted form so that's that Gap here
so when you're resting like this versus
like this the hammer is going to give
you the brachialis as well as the
extended head of the bicep so if you do
hammer curls as well as hyper extended
curls they're going to give you a longer
head for a better rest also
too hot to be wearing a beanie today
just sweating my ass off right now short
in my head it's just full of sweat right
now Jordan Garza uh Story Time thank you
Jordan Garza did we already play this
one
no we didn't no we didn't all right
Jordan guard is uh Jordan Garza with a
tent you'll get your rent
story time we're supposed to see the
first Deadpool with Pops in sixth grade
yes he's a great dad yeah that's awesome
man my dad took me to see species when I
was six years old you guys haven't seen
species look up the plot you should take
all your children to go watch species
but I flipped my teacher off that day
for exposing my grades and couldn't see
it till it came out on DVD oh that's too
bad that's too bad that's such a theater
going experience my first time I saw
Deadpool there was like five people in
the theater
not at all yeah um but Deadpool is such
a magical theater experience I hope they
released one and two before three that'd
be fun to have that Marathon but you
make sure to go opening night there
Jordan Gardens support and I see your
name a lot in these super chess thank
you so much my friend much appreciate
hello wake welcome to being here uh
Derek it's go Chen Noor good Channel
thank you I'm butchering that name but
that's the that's the way to say
everything on YouTube I'm sorry for
butching that name uh if Wade makes a
joke about that the leading seed and
where he gets the suit then my life will
be complete also hoping he makes jokes
about his height I feel like we're gonna
get a joke about it we gotta get height
jokes I think I mean he knows I also
feel like um the the suitcase scene that
might be a different Wolverine I think I
personally I think it'd be really funny
if like a post-credits scene joke was
like those were the different Wolverines
like there is a yellow and brown
Wolverine that is from that movie yeah
and it's like a different Canon because
also weirdly like if you think about
Logan Logan exists in a world where uh
comic books of the X-Men are around so I
feel like that Logan might actually be
different than X-Men 2 Logan true also
Days of Future Past was the first time
travel timey why me movie they could tie
in some ideas of the TVA being after
Wolverine since then because
inexplicably Kitty Pride had these weird
time traveling Powers which made no
sense which is why the movie's excellent
but not as good as people think but like
they could tie in elements of those
continuities to the different suitable
Wolverines and make it all one big fun
joke
okay cool I agree I also think they
should put Hulk in there I'm seeing
people talk argue about it in the chat I
think Hulk should be in this uh as much
as I'd love to be live for hours today
we have to be we do we do we have we're
going to give quality efficient answers
no no we're just way behind on the super
chest we're gonna have quality efficient
answers here and then like five ten
minutes I'm gonna turn them off okay got
five to ten minutes we're gonna have to
turn off the super chat we'll read all
of them but we're gonna get to a point
where we can't uh allow we gotta stop
allowing you guys to be so generous and
contributing who do you think you are
we're those people with your kindness
that's Cara
um I do thank you so much for the Super
Chat my friend I do wish they kept the
suit for theaters but I'm still excited
uh no you're gonna have to promote it
eventually in the in the trailers I feel
like I'll be in the suit for most of the
movie yeah I wanna I wanna actually
comment on this that I feel like this is
kind of like the d23 announcement for
like a week later they just had
Wolverine and Deadpool reveal the movie
that was coming out it is interesting
this is a couple weeks out from
Comic-Con I was wondering if this would
have been part of Marvel's presentation
if Comic-Con had I don't need it they
need save money uh well I was thinking
like remember Disney's losing money
Kathleen Kennedy ruined Marvel go whoa
go bro uh remember when um the Loki suit
uh when like Tom Hiddleston came out in
the suit how perfect would have been and
have Wolverine like in costume show at
all age a big fan of that when they do
that I didn't like it when they did
it for high evolutionary I liked it for
Loki more than high volume I think it
looks cheesy I don't think it actually
ruins it well then Greg one I'm one of
the people who's not a fan I thought
Loki Crush well Loki looks good
I don't know it just it pulls me out
away from the reality of the yeah I'm
not in a movie Why is it yeah yeah yeah
especially when they did for high
Evolution that was a bit much it also
was really long and he's got like the
face and like this now it's just like
fake
distracting but I I would have liked the
suit to be a a reveal but I like that
they're controlling it before it gets
leaked by TMZ looks awful yeah that's
true that's true
uh they're just trying to control the
narrative yeah media controlling all of
our opinions
raccoon shampoo with a 20.
off topic but to clear up my question
about a dancing and Superman gun said he
always includes dancing in his stuff by
the way the dancing and Suicide Squad is
at the club were pom Clementi of candy
there was it there was told there's a
whole day
thank you raccoon shampoo for clearing
that James Gunn does make the dancing
happen whoa Jeff Carroll I see what's
going on here
you actually have a 10. well so would
that 10 in mind when you fix this
hey guys which rumored Deadpool 3 Cameo
appearance are you most excited for who
hasn't been rumored that you'd love to
see for me with succession as my second
all-time favorite show if Brian Cox
shows up as Striker and tells Wade
off I will lose it ooh good question
that's a great great question uh
personally The Cameo I most want to
truly come to fruition as much as I
would love like the uh okay yeah we
could talk forever we've got to be
efficient equality uh so as much as I
would love like the Chris Evans one from
Fantastic Four I feel like there's a lot
of um I'd be very excited to see the one
I'm really hoping does happen is the
Channing Tatum gamut one I feel like
that's likely to happen because Channing
Tatum worked with Ryan Reynolds and Sean
Levy the director of this movie and free
guy so I absolutely think there's a
possibility this one could be pulled off
and he deserves it the Gambit is the one
I want most but since Greg has already
covered that one I think my most
anticipated hopeful one is uh Russell
Crowe turn down Wolverine because he
this isn't joking this is real Russell
Crowe turned down the role of Wolverine
because in Gladiator there was a scene
where he has a wolf and Russell Crowe
thought Wolverines were wolves and
didn't want to be known as the wolf guy
not kidding this happened I would love
if they referenced Russell Crowe and
basically made it like oh the wolf guy
and made it Russell Crooks that's
hilarious to me that one of the biggest
franchises of all time was almost
starring one of the biggest actors of
that time and it was a lack of knowledge
of animals that turned it down so
Russell Crowe he's also who who
recommended Hugh Jackman so it worked
out for the best but Russell Crowe or
Doug Ray Scott who um broke his hand on
the set of Mission Impossible 2 and
therefore didn't get to play Wolverine
he was cast as Wolverine Hugh Jackman
was not the first choice so uh like if
Doug Ray Scott shows up with like a
broken hand or Russell Crowe shows up as
a wolf guy funny to just me yeah Justice
for Gambit uh Captain Kirk captain
what happened did it happen I didn't
know how to read that Captain Captain
Kirk oh okay oh it's a tent we gotta
turn yep you'll get your rent when you
fix this damn chat
hey coin gray do you think Hugh
Jackman's Wolverine still will have a
cow that has the white eyes I don't even
think about the wide eyes and Alden do
you think we'll see a more comic
expressive version of his Berserker rage
we did talk about the berserka ridge
absolutely think so uh
I mean they rarely give Deadpool though
and they keep it emotive they should do
that for Wolf and I think it's the only
world it would fit in I don't think
Wolverine's wide eyes would work in the
X-Men movies this is the time to do it
again that's why they made the suits
brighter again this is gonna be more
comicky I think we get white ad
Wolverine and I think uh Berserker rage
in Logan is exceptional but I think he'd
be more playful with it here so it's
gonna be fun
okay so I got to do that to soak each
other with you on I gotta call him yep
um because people are saying we're in it
that's exciting way to ruin it for us
guys what a surprise God how are you
gonna react to me no yeah I know now
you're gonna walk oh look at us in this
trailer it's exciting is it like on TV
uh it's it's playing in George Lucas's
office right now right now he's like
these rejects they're the future yeah
I'm gonna edit them into the next job of
the Hut special edition Jordan Garza hey
Jordan thanks for coming back in the
chat I told you this guy's always here I
love it uh Q for you both him being one
of my absolute favorite professional
characters I'm hoping we get Silver
Surfer soon who's all's casting maybe
Rami Malek
um
um do you have a particular one I think
I think it would be cool to get Doug
Jones back Silver Surfer there's only
one answer who he is known for his
wisdom he's known for being a man who
looks at the world in a different ways
of concept he's known for surfing and
Point Break Keanu Reeves is
amazing I think it'd be so good I could
hear his voice coming out of the server
and also like the point of the Silver
Surfers to look at Humanity from a
different perspective Keanu Reeves sure
it's so great hand-to-hand combat
surfboard it's everything
he would be good I really like Doug
Jones's interpreter Doug Jones and
Lawrence Fishburne that combo the combo
and Rise of Silver Surfer I think yeah I
I only watched it recently and I was
like this is an underrated Doug Jones is
always I mean I mean but I think the
combo of them was great yeah I thought
that it was actually excellent so
but I feel like Silver Surfer would just
sound like you're a reason yeah
I don't think we'd see feet we're super
present so aware it's Keanu Reeves the
whole time I was so in for his Batman
though that was a blast but that part of
that was supposed to be funny and part
of the funniness was known yeah that's
that would be distracting yeah
but I wouldn't complain either I mean
I'm still happy about it it's exciting
Bucky Barnes Atlanta
on the latest Star Wars YouTube channel
today they showed your reaction Greg it
was the latest Ahsoka video on the
channel maybe you know this God damn a
lot of people keep talking about this
exciting why are so many things
happening today
this is what I'm gonna have a schedule
I'm excited for it so good big old big
old Sarah thank you for letting me know
Bucky Barnes appreciate the Super Chat
my friend okay um listen I gotta be
smart about time as much as I've got
about being here and who the hell on
YouTube doesn't love students hanging
out well I almost just hit enter
I love being here but I'm not I was just
saying the whole screen is so funny
um I I have to okay we're gonna go
through we're gonna finish off all the
super chats gonna check the streams as
well I I do understand the implications
of this action you do yeah but I just
want to make sure that both Coy and I
have a have a full schedule today and I
also I gotta squeeze in an edit for this
Ahsoka trip oh I can also while you're
doing this say uh the reason I today is
so crazy is I've got to prep a panel I'm
hosted Hall h again uh so we're gonna be
announcing uh what's going on there
before our panel so head on over 1pm at
Comic-Con we'll be in the library uh
this Saturday koi has three back-to-back
channels I'm literally going Hall h real
Rejects and one I haven't announced yet
I say back to back I mean he's got a
12-1 and a two it's a lot I'm very
intimidated and I'm gonna be literally
running from one to the next to the next
so my Saturday is bananas it is very
bananas um let's see here sriracha
I I I sometimes like to play into the
fact that I'm I am ethnic and then um
and then sometimes I come across like
the whitest dude it's a good mix oh he's
got he's got a two he's got a two
meeting to ten
you'll get your rent when you fix it
I think no sleeves and big blue gloves
is a bit too cartoony nay I think they
gotta escalate into it and a little bit
more cartoony
the sleeves makes the gloves a bit more
pleasing to the eye in my opinion but I
would love without
um I think you sent your Super Chat
twice so we can answer it refunds
I don't know how to refund it
is there an option to do that I actually
don't know I don't accept your donation
let me know and I'll figure it out we'll
see if there's a way to figure this out
um but yeah I mean do you think I don't
think it'd be too cartoon I feel like
with a movie like this and everything
they're planning on doing I think I
think it totally there's a way to make
it that's again that's why the brighter
red that's why the brighter world I
think that that's a kind of it will
establish a regularity and then when it
rips that can be how it gets to the the
big witness so I think having it with
sleeves for now allows for it to be a
seamless transition into crazy I don't
think Kang will be in uh in this movie
Cooks Lewis
cook Dewey Cox one of the most
underrated comedies Yo Man Wolverine
suit looks cool and awesome man to the
people who would say his would not work
in the movies look at this image look at
it uh Lewis Cox respectfully I don't
think it would have worked in 2001. uh I
do think that we had to get here as a
society accepting of this comic culture
I don't think you could just throw a lot
of people into things you look at blade
he's wearing Matrix outfits blade is
first though by the way fun fact Blake
98 Matrix 99 but if you had to like kind
of like warm the audience up into it I
agree now it looks amazing and we should
look at it but I do think um it had to
get there like we had to get to the
point where Society was like that's
acceptable I mean but I mean look hold
on let me just uh let me just pull this
up on let me just pull this up on screen
briefly only to make my life a little
bit more even more delayed to getting to
the other tasks at hand but like no more
anything but super cheap we gotta talk
about this guys
um so like right here on let me just
adjust this sorry sorry so this is from
the deleted scene of the Wolverine
ignore all the other stuff you see on
screen oh this is from the deleted scene
of Wolverine right and like this cowl
looks great but what I noticed right
away is that they were going to like for
a more contrasted darker yellow it was
the blue yellow it's the easier to
digest and that does and there is a
version of that and it does work that
would have worked for that world maybe
would have worked for that one but I
think for this one they are leaning more
animated like the way how they had
Charles Xavier show up in Multiverse
exactly it's much more like he's in the
chair and he points like it's all those
things I think this would have been the
gateway drug if they'd done it to where
we are now but now we've gotten there
yeah yeah pandemic Jones with 10 one of
our longest Patriots
do you guys agree with people that think
Deadpool 3 is going to suck because of
how fast they are filming them open up
the release date no I don't think that I
just think it shows how much Faith they
have in it much love I mean we don't
know because the thing is we've seen the
quality dip and kind of waver in and out
of some of these Marvel movies in phase
four because it seemed like they were
kind of rushing and just pumping them
out and not really looking at the
quality of them and so that kind of
bleeds into some of the concern I think
regardless even if it doesn't end up
being the best Deadpool movie I want it
to be the best it could absolutely be so
it's like if they can delay it so they
have time to do reshoots if necessary
police for the love of God like if it
needs to be delayed delayed if it needs
to be delayed to make it the best it can
be then do it like there's no
question about that I think regardless
it'll still have some of the best
moments out of any of the Deadpool
movies that we could have ever asked for
yeah what they're building we already
know is huge uh yeah I do want to say uh
I don't think that Ryan Reynolds would
do this if he didn't have full faith in
it like I think this was written the
hell out of 40 years before we got it
greenlit I think that Ryan Reynolds had
this script polished and reworked so
like remember there were a bunch of real
nighters brought on and left I think
Ryan Reynolds cares way too much to let
that happen personally also Hugh Jackman
on top of that wouldn't sacrifice his
legacy as Wolverine if he didn't have
faith in the script and what it was
we've seen a lot of Multiverse content
fail we've seen a lot of this stuff not
work I can't imagine Hugh Jackman with
his love of Wolverine and Ryan Reynolds
love of Deadpool either of them would
sacrifice anything much less both of
them I don't see that happening yeah no
I I mean I feel like the pre-production
the setup and everything before filming
yeah I agree like the concern comes into
you never know what her because a lot of
times you have things in mind and then
you go to film it and then they're
coming out differently you have to
reshoot you have to refill them you have
to rewrite like that's the whole part of
the process of making a film is it's a
discovery process yeah and when you have
a writer strike going on you limit a lot
of that Discovery process to enhance and
make things better or correct upon and
that's the concern here that that's the
only concern that's the only concern
that I have uh but that major concerned
it's my concern but if it was any other
pair I'd be more concerned that's just
like and also Ryan Reynolds has a
billion dollar Gin Company and a mint
mobile and like he doesn't need it he's
good so he's only do this because he
wants to uh raccoon shampoo which MCU
character are you most excited to see
Deadpool interact with MCU character
hmm oh yeah because we got more Deadpool
that's that's the other things yeah
after this yeah we're gonna get more
Deadpool after this uh Spiderman
Spiderman Andrew Garfield as as cliche
of an answer as it is it's got to be
Spider-Man for me man I think
Spider-Man's the answer I'd like to see
him interact with Punisher oh
Ryan Reynolds but I think I feel like
there's a way there's a way to make it
fun uh just uh this is gonna be very
upsetting for a certain audience uh
section but she Hulk uh I think fourth
wall breaking awareness of from two
characters and like the act like she's
the most cartoony one we've had so far
and he's the most cartoony one so it'd
be really fun to have that unreality so
like Spider-Man Punisher She-Hulk
yes
um let's see here Sean Payton thank you
so much my friend biggest question that
needs answered uh will Wolverine say bub
oh he better he better it's about dude
uh yeah no I've been waiting for bub for
a lot of my life do you guys remember in
X2 when they broke into the house and
he's like you came to the wrong house
oh my God that was the first time I
this in my mind that
Berserker rage was pretty incredible
that's to this day one of my favorite
Comics it's an amazing scene because
it's rooted in Emotion despite the fact
there's no blood right it's it's rooted
it's such a protective of rageful
emotion yeah I remember seeing that in
theaters and I was just like in the back
of my chair like oh I wasn't on the edge
of my seat was the other way I was like
pushed back shoot me shoot oh it's so
good one of the best comic scenes to
this day to this deck Kaden Lee Coy
appreciation hey that's it yeah
seriously appreciate you that's worked
out today this is like schedules don't
usually do this costume breakdown are
not my forte I was it was fun so you did
like everything
I was just
Greg called me because what are you
doing this morning and I was like I will
get here and we will do this literally
still waking up by the way I was like up
till 4am so he said what are you doing
existing
and then I pulled photos of costumes
while stuck in traffic to get here
uh Dante back in the chat my friend uh
Wolverine and the claw sheets on top of
the hands exactly I love it I love the
only thing I really picked up costume
nope yeah I'm very do you think we'll
see it come out of him like that
gloveless though I think we're gonna see
uh at one point I think we're getting a
bone Club overeating this
okay I think we're gonna mess around and
find out I think we see all sorts of
claws Wolverine yeah yeah nice call
Austin Daniels what X-Men do you think
they should introduce first I think the
first two should be Cyclops and
Professor X I really want Glenn Powell
as Cyclops uh the X-Men that they should
introduce first
I mean when it makes sense to start with
the X-Men
Xavier I think you need to have Xavier
gather if you're doing like X-Men yeah
he is the X yeah X-Men I mean I feel
like if you're just like any of the
players who go into the field Cyclops
yeah but uh yeah I think it should be
one of one of the two that you are
saying my number one uh I'm so happy for
Glenn he is cast as everyone now he is
The Fan cast guy and that makes me so
happy because that dude is great uh two
uh I would say Cyclops and storm are the
two X-Men that need their own solo
movies most because storm and cyclops
have been like the most abused as far as
like no respect like those are the two
characters that led the X-Men and those
are the two characters like yeah those
side characters I would actually argue
uh I want Wolverine the latest I'd
rather Wolverine be like a third movie
um because he's it's always Wolverine
and friends and though that's a show in
a comic that's not what I want from
these X-Men so uh I I personally love
um the golden blue teams I want those
ripped
uh let's see here let's see here let's
see here let's see here big Jill Studios
super excited for this wonder if a
lecture would get a comic accurate suit
too depending on how much Jen is in it I
feel like when they're going through the
fox Universe characters They're Gonna
Keep it to what they look like in a lot
of ways this is them saying goodbye in a
send-off too for for a lot of them yeah
although how dope would it be if they go
to the X-Men and you get James Marsden
do a fear of cycle finally
everybody gets their one moment of
redemption and it could work because
it's an alternate universe Alan
Richardson is my pick for Cyclops by the
way oh
that is fantastic absolutely my pick for
soccer yeah that's definitely a Jim Lee
Cyclops all chest power all chest chest
clubs
uh Allison Becker 94. I don't know the
conversion but it looks big
oh
name one thing that would change from
the MCU and give Corey a job at Marvel
sending lots of love from Norway we've
had uh someone edit for us from Norway
before great editor
um name one thing you would change from
the MCU uh I would allow it down oh so
Island Richton would be a good saber
tooth oh yeah I like that uh one thing I
change uh I would allow already content
Beyond Deadpool so I want to have a
maturation of the MCU sure it started 15
years ago we're grown-ups uh they're I
want to be all ages though like there
should be stuff that's geared younger to
have new people come in but I I do think
it's uh a maturation is what I'm missing
and um a job at Marvel I have been more
and more thinking of uh becoming a suit
so maybe one day it might be a thing we
don't neglect Gambit we said that that's
the one we wanted yeah that's our number
one what is our neglect are we in the
last live stream we spent so much time
talking about like we're surprised by
how they haven't been able to get Gambit
should be one of the easiest ones not
the easiest ones but he's not a first
step is that what they're referencing
he's not like I don't think he's like an
OG yeah I think you need the original
105 if possible and if you extend then
like I think storm is important I think
if you start with the X-Men already
established then you need like a core 10
Gambit could be in that but I really
think they should start small and expand
Diego Guevara hey Diego nice to see you
again buddy
that's wrong Knives Out has Craig
smoking multiple times in his PG-13 you
dumbass
yeah yeah that's what I got Google is
wildly inconsistent also someone with a
name without any vowels some
like yeah right give him a job at Marvel
when he always forget storylines and
characters you do this live and you
let me know how it goes when you're
having this much data in your head and
you're doing it for thousands of people
that are going to correct you because
I'm doing all right you didn't you
didn't catch the extremists
also called gwenpool Gwen Stacy and uh
people were very upset about that
because it's a different character but
it's obviously based off the idea of a
Gwen Stacy very who do I think I
am only knowing thousands of comics at a
time uh let's see here aniso Liva hey my
dear love Anissa oh yeah she's great
she's a friend oh my God a long time no
see miss you guys a lot hopefully going
to make a trip to La soon again love
y'all also love the shirt Greg this is
from Anissa oh I love that makes me
happy I love you miss you Anisa just hit
me up sometime dear miss you
uh Collide notice Wade's crotch and left
hand we did oh I'll notice oh oh Coy
broke it down don't you even work broke
down I got that crotch on lock now when
you say we're in the Ahsoka trailer guys
is it like uh like a like like five is
it one of those things where there was
like a reaction sometimes they put us
and stuff for a little bit and it's like
a second yeah you're like oh yeah well
we gotta find out and I'm like what do
you mean it's not just us for three
minutes on screen they're not just
playing us yeah is it not just a replay
of our video they should get Kiki Palmer
for rogue and then get her boyfriend to
play Gambit who's your boyfriend oh he
loves the way she dresses
oh that douche
oh hey Jay Bristol
and then
press tall
what a week
um oh yeah I need for this move thank
you for the Super Chat it's Hugh Jackman
a stare at a photo of Gene and cyclops
like the animated that was one of my
favorite memes of all time when people
just put anything in that frame I
laughed it's a catch-all they gotta have
Deadpool making fun of him screaming
June oh I'd love that so much that's
like half his lines yeah in the show no
in the movies too oh that's true
no that's all of the Wolverine
no I would love if we find out the
Multiverse Wolverine by him holding
frames of first Sophie Turner and then
uh yeah
that's how they announced the new Jean
Gray it's who he's holding in a frame oh
oh I love this super Sidra zaidi
thank you for Super Chat you need to get
a chance in your sound machine goddamn
right oh what happened enhance that's a
good idea next costume breakdown enhance
I get I'll call John and tell him to
come over
dude that just soaked the trailer John
John Ahsoka we're gonna be in the Ahsoka
show guys we're in this show we're
reacting to what's happening it's it
like it's it's a new thing they're
experimenting with where when the
episode's playing you could watch our
reaction to the Epic we already shot all
the reactions fourth wall breaking in
real time it's basically they pan over
from the set and then it's just Greg and
John like watching them film uh you
could be scroll Vibes real through and
Cave uh thank you my friend can't stay
long just wanted to say you all rock you
rock real through on your huh what a
kind you rock thank you so much Chris
Mullins I hope they show an alternate
version of Wolverine's Weapon X from Age
of Apocalypse on his full on feral form
they do got to kind of do some clarity
there yeah I I do think the bone claw
Wolverine is going to be feral and I'd
love to see uh the one-handed Wolverine
from Weapon X uh era Age of Apocalypse
but that was such a conflicting Cameo
from him in uh which one was that
apocalypse yeah when because it because
it's like that was a great scene didn't
need it a lot of sense but it was great
but it sure did mean he played him 10
times yeah it was I felt like it was it
was a quota like he's like I gotta hit
that Guinness mark this is it's so funny
yeah James desio thank you for Super
Chat just need someone to photoshop at
orange and brown that is my favorite
Wolverine suit but I do think the blue
and yellow is more iconic to the the
fandom real rejects forever that's the
name of our fourth YouTube channel
it's coming don't worry just like
forever right huh
let's see here Aisha Kenya hey dear
hello hello my friend
chat hey handsome fellas hey beautiful
lady
can we see Tara nitrogen as a wolverine
variant or maybe just as Wolverine
himself uh might be a fun tease for the
audience like John Krasinski as read
if they'll go that far I think they're
going to want to keep it just on um Hugh
but then we might get they should get
Doug Ray Scott that's what I was saying
earlier with a broken hand did you see
that yeah probably focus on the tech you
were doing a lot uh I was saying what's
my ultimate Cameo I said it'd be really
funny if they had Russell Crowe as
Wolverine and Doug Ray Scott as
Wolverine that would be fun because
that's how it all like that I'd like
that but he's in a cast it's like yeah
that'd be funny
hey Salient uh thank you thank you Aisha
thanks Salient thank you so much hey
guys what do you think the cow is going
to look like smaller ears or taller ears
I feel like it I feel like it'll just be
a different color than what I pulled up
on screen earlier
right like I think it'll look like I
feel like that's the way to do it like
the side Focus it's really about like a
big sign like what was crazy about this
image is that it's pretty comic accurate
for the most good especially for the
time like this this if Casey guys don't
know I mean most of you probably already
know by now this is the deleted scene
like they actually filmed this for the
Wolverine yeah and and you could you
could find you can watch the latest
scene on YouTube and so this is a pretty
accurate uh cow
um but I think it'll be more color
coordinated because this color would not
match with no with with that Wolverine
yeah that's weird it wouldn't match it
um so yeah that's what I imagine
um I think the ears will be
mid middle height mid to answer
yeah X thank you all for being here this
is a fun fun morning stream thank you
guys so much really really do appreciate
it thank you X Primal impulse and thanks
for coming over here last minute got you
I hope Wolverine and Colossus do a
fastball special
explain I didn't even think of the
likelihood of that which is fine you got
30 seconds okay when uh Colossus picks
up Wolverine and he throws them as like
a bullet oh yes yes
but like that wouldn't have worked
totally in any of the movies yeah that'd
be um because Colossus is a core
Deadpool like team member I didn't put
that together we're probably getting a
fastball special
this changes everything oh yeah this
would be the first time this Wolverine
could interact with this Colossus
because there was a Colossus in the
accident Daniel cutmore but they didn't
it was too it wasn't big enough yeah
this Colossus is bigger and he wasn't
Russian genius was he Russian he wasn't
Russian yeah yeah she's a nice guy
Daniel but that'd be amazing Arthur uh
Vega Arthur Vega oh
no you'll get your rent when you fix
this damn chat hey guys hope you and the
chat have a good day oh we're having a
good day we're having a great day having
a great day it's Deadpool over index
it's Deadpool Wolverine day guys
thank you Arthur Vega
jahashiel para Netflix's Daredevil is
the best comic book adaptation of all
time it is my favorite
I think it is still my favorite of the
MCU
uh I'm reading season one Infinity War
in-game Batman center cut Joker load Etc
uh I don't know about comic book
adaptation of all time but I think out
of the MCU is still my favorite person I
think it's my favorite thing Marvel's
adapted because I think no way home and
winter soldier mean a lot to me but I
think Daredevil is is it's if it's not
number one it's top three season one is
like it's so perfect perfect it's so
good perfect yeah no I and I don't think
it can be topped uh it's it's Immaculate
too perfect yeah
Colossus does throw Wolverine and Last
Stand when they're in the Hologram room
and oh but they don't show it oh that's
right then then the head yeah and then
the head gets locked it's an implied
fastball special which is like come on
it's like implied nudity this one's for
you morph uh Collide back in the chat
tonight
DC Studios is reportedly interested in
casting Asian American actors for the
role of Batman thoughts
sure
I don't care someone's good at playing
Batman he has a mask on
it doesn't matter yeah and as long as
you guys go to play I mean Batman's more
about it's not like it'll be like it's
obviously that Asian billionaires that
appears Asian yeah yeah
what does it matter to me Henry Golding
would be a great Bruce Wayne yeah that
guy's fantastic it'd be a great one he's
so good in gentlemen yeah
yeah cast someone good and I'll be happy
I don't care I could care less
I don't know if that's a good thing or a
bad thing but I'm just like good yeah
I would love it I would love for it to
be uh it's as long as it's a good
casting doesn't mean yeah
Bucky Barnes Atlanta back at it can you
say FU ryanairy again love that guy well
it was part of being that funny was that
there was a bleep there there's this
thing that I did for a video that's been
cut clipped out a lot okay you Ryan
area and that's a ryanairy Ryanair from
screen Crush you racist
our Asian American Screen Crush host oh
I don't know screen Crush dude YouTube
channel he's massive he's one of the
biggest YouTuber Twitter he's a friend
of mine oh it but it's huge met up with
him and he came out here yeah
I'm in a group chat with him it's a it's
a show is it a shower Channel
yeah internet stuff Ryan Airy this is
why no one likes you Coy No one that's
why you're only hosting three panels
I'm sorry I like real life and not
Digital Life it alarms me also someone
said oh yeah he's throwing a Magneto and
uh
in uh days that uh at X3
look we just we didn't redo everything
from X3 all right I need to re-watch X3
because I don't have fond memories Sean
Payton all right guys look we got we got
only got a couple minutes ago we really
gotta wrap this okay I mean but I want
to make sure we do it we got to do them
all okay yes
should I give you a solid 90 minutes
doing it you guys
koi give Sean Payton Deadpool and
Wolverine Comic recommendations make it
snappy uh X-Men
um the nope negate that uh Deadpool
X-Men I was gonna give some numbers
it wasn't accessible so I'm switching it
out uh Deadpool The Good the Bad and the
Ugly it's a trade paperback that I adore
Wolverine Captain America and Deadpool
all team up very very good stuff uh
there's a two issue series from Rob
leifeld where Deadpool Wolverine they're
on the covers I do believe it was part
of the uh I think it was a Wolverine I
think it's in the hundreds but look up
Deadpool Wolverine Rob liefeld it's in
it's in the first volume of Wolverine
after his mini series it was in the Deep
hundreds those are two great issues uh
I'd also recommend the Deadpool Dead
Presidents Run for the vibe that Ryan
Reynolds is and I'd recommend the
Wolverine run uh Wolverine agent of
shield which is going to be a little bit
darker and a little bit more in the vein
that I think they're gonna take this
since it's gonna be R-rated uh but the
number one would definitely be um
Deadpool The Good the Bad and the Ugly
because it's not only my favorite
Deadpool Wolverine team up it's actually
my favorite Deadpool run of all time and
if you want Wolverine x23 who I adore
there is a few issues in the Tom Taylor
run of Wolverine which is the The x23
Wolverine that Deadpool is best friends
with bet honey badger who is the uh
little sister of x23 and their
relationship is one of the most precious
in comics that's a nice one koi ready
you did great I'll read those a month
before this movie and I'll you'll run
I'll you'll ask me I'll remind you and
they're great you know how it goes yeah
let's jam it all in last minute oh
Jeremiah
which you have koi is the jack nerd we
all want to be that's what he's aiming
for I got them gold them testosterone
pills he takes one day I'm gonna get I'm
gonna get to the point I need him but
not yet not yet uh I will just take him
I'll take steroids do whatever it takes
I mean I I followed this guy that was
like natural it was naturally enhanced
on Tick Tock and then he just like got
really really jacked and he was like I
think I trust error and see if I can get
bigger and I was like I respect that
like he he was honest and then he's like
I'm done being natural and I was like
cool uh I personally uh like my balls
the size they are so I'm not doing
steroids but I think one day be fun uh
that said uh I think people that read
Comics looking like a comic character is
a really cool uh motivator so I've
always I've never understood the nerd
Judgment of people that go to the gym I
think it's really weird that people are
like I love these fit characters but I
hate the gym I personally uh want to
live as long as possible healthily and I
think that the gym is a really good
therapy and I also think it like makes
all your happy chemicals better so I'd
highly recommend if you want to try the
gym out to look like the characters we
love so much yeah exactly I'm way less
it's my mental it's biggest part of my
mental health right at the gym and like
the fact that I didn't work out this
morning because because of this because
I I discovered this but like it really
affects your whole like day to day you
know it's effective like I've noticed
I'm just not as like sharp and focused
right now yeah it's a different day and
specialist but good I'd rather be here
right now
um uh let's see Tristan Clark
told you we do not end the stream
without going through the mall
hey hey great to see you live again by
the way Coy love the cut and the comic
recommendations do you guys think this
will possibly be a fun way to lay the
fox Universe to rest to let them be
reborn in the MCU I think that's the
biggest part of what they're aiming for
here I mean we're getting like all the
payoffs that we wanted so we this is
going to be like a closure movie you
know one thing that I think that when we
often think about the Deadpool films is
we think about the humor a lot of the
time the how funny it is what I think a
lot of the but the magic ingredient to
them has been the heart yeah both one
and two and especially two a lot of
people just kind of don't seem to like
when they think back on it it's like
there's so much emotion in those movies
yeah especially part two it gets like
pretty serious at times and I think this
will have a a bit of a like a truly
heartwarming goodbye like it'll be funny
right but I feel like it's gonna get you
in the feels a little bit more than
we're actually expecting it to they'll
advertise it like a comedy but just like
the first Deadpool that movie's love
story I think the best romance in comic
books is Deadpool I honestly like they
advertised it uh Valentine's Day as a
ROM comment it was like it was cheeky
but it was sincere and I think the heart
of Deadpool the thing I like about
Deadpool is that he wears a mask not to
protect his identity but it's protect
you from seeing his face because he's so
insecure about how ugly he is that's
Deadpool he's all heart and so is Ryan
Reynolds Ryan Reynolds is Van Wilder
Shore but the best Ryan Reynolds is the
fact that he loves us so much and he
cares about this character so much and
like that is going to be the heart of
this so I think the the fox
sentimentality is going to be really
brutal and this movie's gonna be amazing
maybe you should take that advice from
Deadpool about Mass score yeah it's on
me huh no keep trying everything keep
working out just keep nothing solving
this problem I just can't I need you
then yeah just it's time I need you to
time to brown bag it myself just the old
school brown bag
um uh it's happened it's happened I saw
that I'm only catching everything there
it is all right it's finally hey you
know what everybody's got a different
take I saw Jeremy Johns gave a good time
no alcohol required when you gave
Fallout awesome tacular so it was like
this is not we're not alone I love it I
love that we said we liked it we just
liked other ones in the same franchise
more yeah and then the whole chat is
like so do we love everything really
hate everything which one is it that's
the internet do we love everything
that's why I don't know what a screen
crush is yeah because the internet's
dark and awful Reynaldo Torres Torres do
you believe Kang will have an appearance
no I don't think they're I think there's
gonna be the TVA there's gonna be
reference there could be references to
King but I don't think there'll be I
don't think Kang will actually appear
yeah especially when they're gonna throw
Jonathan Majors on a Marvel set right
now we gotta avoid and simple I think
some that would have leaked in some way
you know problematic that would
have been for people despite whatever it
is you believe it would cause problems
all right why do you know it would cause
problems lucky BX here's a fun fact fun
fact thank you luck VX fun fact is I'm
thankful for you the woman playing
Fury's wife also played his mom in
Unbreakable in glass
no really I love that I had no idea
that is a fun fact damn lucky BX amazing
that is a really fun fact I am I adore
that uh also angel of death in the chat
uh Spider-Man Deadpool isn't it romantic
is uh my number two uh favorite Deadpool
run of all time so I also recommend that
to you lovelies great great pull Samir
battenfield thank you so much love your
videos I'm glad I can make this live do
you think dp3 would be the Cameo festive
people thought Doctor Strange was going
to be I don't think it'll be I don't
think anything's ever going to be the
Cameo Fest that people thought Doctor
Strange is going to be to the point of
where we thought it would be the most
gnarly amount there were like 40 cameos
being you know rumored for that film
yeah so no I don't think it's going to
be that crazy but do I think it'll be
crazier than than Multiverse it already
is yes just just by alone the leads are
yeah totally you know we didn't do so we
didn't do a breaking news live with
Multiverse Madness images came out
that's how big this will rain images I I
think it'll be more than Multiverse
Madness but I don't think anything will
ever reach the level maybe Secret Wars
but maybe I don't think uh I don't think
this will be that big and I would I mean
it'd be cool if that the thing is like
cameos are not always handled the best
you know that's the thing it's like
cameos tend to sound so exciting on
paper and then when they happen you're
like it's just not as novel anymore
people expect it it's not like oh my God
it's no it's awful and you need it to
have a little bit of substance yeah and
I think sometimes the substances is
definitely lost but that's what I think
we will get here like we said with the
heart Rachel Knight online thank you so
much for the Super Chat my friend
immediately got an hour and a half of
filming right after this
chat Siri Deadpool is running from the
TV it ends up falling out of time and
landing in the middle of this very into
Wolverine and Norton's Hulk where
they're about to fight in order to talk
will be a fun Cameo
um I think I think I think I think uh uh
Eric Bana would be a more fun Cameo
honestly if Ed Norton's Hulk is fighting
the mustache I mean the whiskers
Wolverine sure sure that would be the
funniest thing if we have Wolverine with
his whisker suit which is his first
appearance fighting Ed Norton my God
um I love that thank you is this a an
actual thing that happened I mean is
this a leak I don't know I'm honestly
not familiar that familiar with the
leaks um I've potentially like kind of
like let's see but yeah I mean I think
for sure the TV is going to be in there
and they're going to be also uh you know
reprimanding him representing yeah
definitely
because of the events of Deadpool three
that double two I think yeah at the end
of Deadpool two he's breaking the TV
apparently we we say the multi the the
verse word differently I never noticed
that I say Multiverse Jet Li's the one
oh and I said that's how he says it
that's interesting the Multiverse
it's because it's gently everything when
I say Multiverse because I read it in
comics a lot there's an eye this is my
first Multiverse movie the one did
Multiverse before Multiverse movies the
one is so slept on Jason Statham jet
leader this is his first American movie
if I'm not mistaken really yeah and then
he immediately did transporter and then
the new metal sound of that movie The
soundtrack's so good yeah like drowning
pool Disturbed yeah that's awesome that
the Bodies Hit the Floor song did not
bode well soon thereafter uh yeah and
then it ends would caught by life into
pieces
yeah he's finding all the people in the
pyramid dude new metal I am nobody's
but you are mine
what's the one now I know the one we
should react to the one with cards
it's my first rewatch but Greg's 80th
that'd be a fun video
Sean Payton thank you so much could this
be Kevin fact farewell to the fox
Universe yes I think so you think this
will be where we met meet our MCU X-Men
no I don't think this will be the one
where we meet them I think this is our
goodbye I don't think this is gonna be
the trend this is like the way where we
can eventually transition sure
um but I think they need to put a final
stamp on it they're smart about it yeah
it's a lot to do in a movie already uh
who will be the leader of the team
because you know like the X-Men
franchise is also huge like I see how
you can just reboot Fantastic Four so
you can just reboot the other ones but
but I think for X-Men you do need to
have a little bit of a goodbye
considering the fact 10 movies
yeah huge franchise yeah so you know and
there's a lot of things that never came
to pass that they can throw in here
which is fun they get that that goodbye
I think Deadpool this is the beginning
of Deadpool in the MCU but it's mainly
about the end of fox yeah let's see also
Kevin feige a lot of people don't
realize was like on set with Lauren
Schuler Donner and that whole team for
Brian singer's X-Men he's the reason
Wolverine has the right hair I do think
there's some catharsis for or Kevin
feige with this film
Mars ate Productions do you think now
that X-Men are coming uh in Hulk rights
or Disney's now do you think we will get
Hulk versus Wolverine prediction how
they make it happen that is one I've
been wanting I've been championing it
for years I would love for Guillermo del
Toro to do it that way you can also get
a Hulk in practice I think he would
Champion to do I would prefer it
personally to be like an R-rated one-off
instead of some MCU thing yeah where you
can get like Guillermo del Toro to do it
where he he's like like you get some
giant guy in makeup you know and then
like first perspective it
what Wolverine's gotta be tiny
Hulk's like 12 feet minimum maybe maybe
15. yeah there's a way you can do it all
right I mean if you've seen those
Hellboy movies he gets like that's some
really cool Giants in there yeah that's
true you're not wrong there's some like
math there's like 10 foot tall people
that they get that's true
The Longest Yard oh yeah now that
Porsche perspective would totally work
with that but he's not I mean they've
got like a 10 foot tall actor yeah
he's a giant he was like 10 feet I meant
for this I would love that I think
that's the way to do it
have you read ultimate X-Men versus
Wolverine
the comic ages ago yeah you rip some
half tourism across the country that was
great that'd be dope I'd love to see him
I mean I think I think it would be
better as an R rated one-off but yeah
they'll never I don't think they're ever
going to do one-offs here not anymore
that's why DC might be stronger in the
long run
um
stuffer
what if this is not Fox Wolverine but
his Deadpool coming to the real world
recruiting Hugh Jackman the actor to
help in his mission and just put him in
that suit just because
I think that would be funny I think that
would also be remarkably disappointing I
do not think it would upset a lot of
people that is certainly not what
they're going to do I I feel like
there's no way in hell or that that's
going to be a chance but it's funny it's
a funny idea for like a sketch remind me
I got a not a movie uh Scripps Trilogy I
wrote with something in that vein I'm
gonna tell you about after okay good I
have plenty of time to hear your full
pitch
if I'm gonna sit down I'm gonna pitch
him he's gonna bring him to his people
um
yeah the wrestler
Milo 99 thank you it's great to see my
cousins work finally out to the word for
for the world for everyone to see The
Wolverine costume oh oh that's awesome
so thank you to your cousin dude it's
gorgeous we lost our minds did you
played them the beginning of this is
your cousin like
hey man I haven't heard from you in
years but now that you know that I've
worked on The Wolverine costume now
you're wanting to talk to me all of a
sudden you're like yeah I see how it is
the kind of cousin you are Milo 99. I
hope you've stayed friends beyond their
Wolverine skill that's why you got to be
close with everyone because you never
know when you might be able to get some
of that nepotism action yeah suit making
that's what I'm talking about stay close
be good with everyone you might be able
to ride off their coattails one day
thank you cousin I think I have faith in
this guy playing the whole game one day
he's gonna be so big and I'm gonna be
like when I was like hey
I'm gonna know every YouTube channel and
I know everyone it's gonna be great
Johnny thank you Johnny you know they're
releasing Avengers public Wars 2028.
yeah
yeah oh Secret Wars public Wars let's
see what he did there yeah it's nice and
I got your jokes that's great I actually
I actually was processing all the
different Avengers Comics trying to yep
I see what's the podcast of fall from
every spoilers it's on his channel it
premieres every Tuesday it's called the
cross the spoiler verse clever um we're
almost at the end here so a 90 minute
mark
if you count the restart it's 90 minutes
what do you think about possibly having
Deadpool
as Blake Lively as Lady Deadpool I mean
I think it'd be a fun Cameo I feel like
that's the one of the I don't think it'd
be a James Gunn wife situation
even though she's a phenomenal
actress whenever she appears she's like
hey James gone his wife like she's a
great actress
like Lively did it it would be more
because it's it's such an awareness of
Ryan Reynolds the personality right also
Blake Lively like was a big actress
before she married Ryan Reynolds and I
think that people Miss Blake Lively like
I feel like there's a and she's so good
in that shark movie what was the what
was the show she was on that was big uh
Gossip Girl yeah like she had a market
of an entire demographic that I think
would be happy to see her I said her as
gwenpool who is in Quinn Stacy uh and I
think that'd be fun to have her or Emma
Stone as gwenpool for that little nod
but I would also love to see Lady
Deadpool Alan richin is awesome I was
weirdly thinking today when and this
morning I was like I wonder when there's
gonna be another Reacher season is the
bomb
um
uh classic Wolverine and Deadpool Hulk
smash your mom says it equals this Emoji
yeah respect what's this Emoji it's a
boner oh
is that what that means yeah it's like a
dick and the just in general but it's
hard on top
to all of our female guests they love it
I thought it meant like hey come over
have some squash and then that's why
there's way less of them now yeah now
the eggplant uh is not a pitch uh well I
guess to some men who died I thought it
just meant if you have dinner if you're
hungry I could bring you a snack before
filming I think that's also what they
implied but the snack was different
which is inappropriate
all the timing of that I really want to
hear Deadpool say it's Morven time
before a fight scene hey if it doesn't
want to pull it off it's gonna be
Deadpool that'd be fun I'd enjoy that
all right but we don't know what we got
we got a lot of quick ones here ricoy
you know how we do
it's
it's constant
all right all right we got something
yeah we're gonna be you're right back to
July 8th
okay what's today 10th got you here I
have a panic I saw that I saw the
scrolling
scrolling scrolling scroll you said
scrolling I've been talking about
Scrolls a lot scrolling
oh let me adjust this
I got this
oh my God I don't got this
I got this he got this
all right the last last round's here I
got a hard hard out
[Music]
I think it's Ronan and chain begins us
yes Ronan hopefully see you a comic
comment he says gentlemen holy
can't believe it's actually happening
imagine when he puts on the mask this is
going to be like Lethal Weapon in
comparison to Deadpool 2 that is more
like 48 hours in terms of banter can't
wait to see all sdcc Ronin Unchained I
can't wait for you to come by say hi
make sure to snap a photo with koi as
he's rushing out to go to his next panel
uh but yeah I would love to talk with
you thank you so much man and yeah
that's the thing I'm looking forward to
most is the the kind of 90s 90s 80s 90s
uh buddy cop yeah I can't wait I'm so
excited and like the buddy cop genre is
my favorite of all genres so if you add
Deadpool will ring to that oh that's why
they're making Wolverine Black this time
yep he's too old for this issue yeah
Michael Mack thank you so much my friend
do we think Deadpool will follow kill
Fox Universe characters himself or
accidentally cause her death I think he
will intentionally no I think it could
be a hybrid of like the
I think they'll do a little bit of a
hybrid I think he's accidentally gonna
kill uh the entire universe but he might
be hired to kill someone and that causes
a cascading effect yeah but I do think
it's going to be more accidental because
he's coming into the MCU as a good guy
yeah maybe some of them would be
portrayed as villains possibly I think
they're going to be portrayed exactly
how they were before suit looks dope
odds on evans's human torch likely
likely very likely big love as always
from Scotland I hope he shaves his head
like he used to too I hope it's Chris
looking like this as human torch I think
he's going to be bearded Chris I don't
think he's gonna go that all out he's
got yeah he's got other things yeah
we love you Chris Cameo it's a game I
mean you got it you gotta do it collide
thank you so much what are you guys most
excited for in the upcoming Batman and
also in the upcoming Batman part two for
me I would really need a fearful Batman
Done Right without killing also an
inverted would be great in live action
really quick Cosmo taste and I see you
thank you for the Super Chat my friend
thank you good to see you thank you
buddy
um what I'm most excited for is to have
the way think of it like this how we're
getting like this animated version of
like Deadpool and here the comics
accurate I feel like the one in that
there's there's two kinds of comics
actor version you could do of Batman so
to make a quick summary on my thoughts
on it is that you're gonna get two
different Comics accurate version of
Batman because in a lot of ways the
Pattinson version is the comics version
that everyone has wanted but that is
also the grounded realistic take of
doing it in terms of like the film Noir
ethos of it all and then I think in uh
the James Gunn Universe it'll be more uh
like colorful and you can get like a
Lazarus Pit and a clay face like that I
think we get Blue and Gray in uh for
lack of uh more Nuance I think we get
blue and gray ask Batman and James Gunn
and black and gray Batman and memories
big doobies thank you for this streamlab
for clarification who Jackman was
actually Harry in Days of Future Past
okay he was he was he was in the 70s
I think because he's so cut through it
it goes past the hand even somehow know
yeah it's just so much ABS but that's
what I mean he doesn't want to lie on a
shave that's impressive he doesn't need
to he's Hugh Jackman is that Jack do you
know how hard it is to be so jacked it's
through hair good night rejects are the
best thank you thank you so much uh in
uh the Mall Rats when the sniggity snake
snake happens at the mall that is now
extra cool because Jay named his
daughter Logan guys this has been a
blasty blast of a stream koi did you
have fun I had so much fun are you glad
you came over here I'm so glad this
timing worked out Against All Odds I'm
glad you came over here too uh we got a
really packed day and also I gotta find
a time to make a video for this Ahsoka
trailer apparently um because apparently
we're in it that's cool look at that
damage I'm still excited God yeah guys
list your nitpicks Down Below on your
way out if you could leave a like on
this video I want to thank everyone who
contributed to our streamlined super
chess and if you didn't that's A-Okay I
want to thank everyone who's been here
in the chat these are the kind of live
streams you'd love doing the most when
it's just spontaneous unprepared uh
that's my favorite kind of uh live
streams to do so thank you all so much
maybe we will get a Loki season two
trailer this month uh your love and
support means the world make sure to
check us out sdcc that's San Diego
Comic-Con the Saturday of Comic-Con 1
p.m Saturday SDC it's gonna be amazing
and uh koi let me do my Flex first
because it's not as big and now koi you
go in there and oh my God the definition
see you guys peace out reject Nation
much love this was